welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is heisha mazouz today i'm really
excited to be joined by john dyson
who is the founder of fjr group john has
worked in the recruitment industry for
over two decades
and in this time he built himself a
successful career
uh progressing through the ranks to
direct a level of robert half within
seven years
and before then and he then decided to
start his own recruitment business in
2011
and for the last decade john has been
dedicated to growing the fjr group who
now have
multiple brands within the group across
finance tech
hr and executive search they're
currently nearly 50 strong
with offices across the uk and soon to
be in the states
and their ultimate vision is to be in 25
locations and to be doing 25 million
pounds toner in each location
in 25 years john welcome to the podcast
thank you very much great to be here so
where you always like to start
million pound question so in your
opinion
what characteristics characteristics and
traits do you think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant and
i i think there's like all things fairly
fairly varied um
i think the great thing about
recruitment is we're selling to
uh so many different characters
personalities
and i suppose character traits uh on the
other side of the fence
that i think there are certainly you
know your common traits that that come
out the determination
the competitive element and all the rest
of it but i do think that
you know one of the things that we try
to have
um within fjr is it is a balance
of characters a balance of traits
because i don't
necessarily think that if everyone is
you know has that sort of complete has
to be number one
competitor instinct to all the rest of
it when you start to build teams you
need to start to try and grow
you can't all be number one at the same
time you want to foster that level of
competition
um but i think you know one of the
things that certainly as
we grew the is business know you need a
blend of personalities
you know i think we always look for
someone who who has got that just
natural inquisitiveness you know i think
the great thing about recruitment is you
can go into most people's business
regardless of you know
what level you're operating at and you
can ask some really intelligent
questions and understand what's going in
those businesses
and you know i think personally for me
that level of inquisitiveness
starts to then uncover not just on the
client side but on the candidate side as
well
how people are going to sort of fit into
into a business so certainly the
inquisitiveness
um and i think you know the
old-fashioned working hard
determination however you want to badge
that one up but
yeah recruitment is is a tough game um
and
you need someone who's got that level of
resilience that can
can keep going when the chips are down
and you know i think certainly the best
people i've seen
have had that sort of natural
intelligence inquisitiveness
but but they've also got a very steely
core you know where they're very
clear in terms of you know what they
need to do how they need to do it
and that resilience to to commit to
achieving that
nice i think they're probably the big
ones that i would i would look for and
then outside that
you've got all the soft skills and all
the rest of it but but i think then it's
about blending as you look at your team
so i have to ask you this because we're
actually doing um an event on it this
month
and i just find it's fascinating so
obviously you always typically hear
resilience and recruitment hand in hand
right i think you possess it
yeah it's interesting i don't i don't
think
uh so an example is
yeah i was at a barbecue in
2000 and 2006
2006 so i was at a bbq um maybe a little
bit before that
and um we were all having a few beers
and it was like right yeah
what's the toughest thing you can do
what's the toughest thing you know
lads around a barbecue i was probably
late
20s maybe just 30 then um
and it was like someone said right it's
the marathon de sabler which is like
six marathons in seven days through the
sahara desert carry all your own food
and all the rest of it
and uh me and a very good friend but all
right yeah we'll do that
oh my god and uh so on the monday we
entered
we were like okay we'll enter and we've
all i've always been
fit but not like super marathon fit or
anything like this
um and yeah we're on like a two-year
waiting list so we're in for 2007
and uh ultimately the the iran-iraq war
kicked off
a load of people got sort of uh sort of
brought in
and we were on a waiting list and you
get a call you go you're on the waiting
list
are you serious or not and once you go
yes i am you sort of
and clearly for two years bragging
bragging to my mates about it i'm gonna
do this
um and then one day i got a call and
they're like
uh you've got a place um
that was in the september uh so that was
september 06.
um my son was born my first son was born
in september 6 and then the the race was
in uh
april 07. um and
clearly i turned up yeah with with my
you know
i can do anything recruitment attitude
we we're
bloody good at what we do um and i think
you know once i was there i realized i
was so far out of my depth
it's ridiculous but
i suppose when i when the race started
day one you find the adrenaline all the
rest of it and then suddenly you realize
oh my god
i've got to do this i've got i've got
another 140 miles to go
through the desert i'm eating
crap food on a little hexy stove i'm
sleeping on the floor of a desert
i can't have a shower um i've got no
home comforts
whatsoever because i can only carry
you're only allowed to carry what you
carry
yeah yeah and and it's like right you're
in
and the amount of people that had
iron men tattooed all down their legs
and they'd done multiple
triathlons and you know adonis of men
and women just crashed
day two ten fifteen twenty thirty forty
fifty people just dropped out
just dropped it they're like i can't do
it i can't yeah yeah they're like
but you there's nothing wrong with you
you know
and i suppose my attitude i started
pretty well
performance went down but it's like i
will not not finish
i will put one foot in front of the
other and i will keep going and i kept
thinking to myself well
you know during the war people had their
arm blown off
and walked out the desert you know i've
got a few blisters
so just keep going and i think
that level of resilience i didn't
realize i had that level of resilience
in the workplace it doesn't come out
quite in the same way yeah of course
it's extreme that that that was probably
the first time in what i was in my early
30s then
that i really realized that when when i
put my mind to something
it's about it was it was pain it was
emotional
it was you know your tent got blew away
at night so you didn't even have good
night sleeps you know
you literally got up at six o'clock in
the morning it'd take me half an hour to
get my shoes on because i had all these
blisters my toenails were coming off and
all the rest of it was like
i will not quit you know i will not
quit i will i will keep going um
and we went there's one stage which is
on day four
and it's you you you it's it's a 60-mile
stage and you go through the night
and i'm doing my mate and after two days
i was like look you're much fitter than
me you trained properly you did all the
research
you're a bastard but well done crack on
yeah i'll just
i'll i'll see you at the tent at night
but don't worry i'll always make it
and there was a stop where you could
stop at night and they'd sort of built
an area where you could bed down and
then continue the next day if you wanted
to stop
and i found a number of people from my
tent
and they were all fitter than me they
were they were all more prepared for me
and they were sitting around a little
fire crying and i was like oh my god
what are you doing what are you doing
they were just broken and it was yeah i
remember it was like
just pick them up guys we are doing this
this is part of this
it's not about you you need to go
through the night we can make so much
time
and just bringing that group through
that resilience
i was like i i wasn't ever sure
demonstrating that and i don't think you
either have it or you don't
there's no at that point when you've
been stripped bare of
all the other things that's when you
really know you've got it and it's tough
to find that in people it's tough to
find it in an interview
because yeah you know but it is trying
to dig into some of those things where
people have really been up against
something
and what have they done yeah what a
great story and honestly that
the whole sort of um i'm absolutely
fascinated with sort of
ultra runners and things like that
because like it's what you're talking
about it's that
sort of realization of what you're
capable of
yeah which must just be this amazing
crazy feeling of like oh my
like what else can i do in my life if i
really put my mind to it as you said
yeah and it's like wow look but
i guess i guess i have to ask like where
like you said
obviously you possessively don't i then
i then feel like that
a lot of that can be created
and formed in sort of early parts of
your life so i have to ask like what
what was what was it like if you growing
up then where like do you feel like
your child had an impact on this or i
have to ask um
i i had a really privileged background
so i i
i was very lucky i was i was born in
japan
um i spent my informative years
in the far east um i went to boarding
school from the age of eight
so i think wow probably that level of
independence
you know i used to fly around the world
on my own at
eight and a half um wow and and so
you know i suppose that level of
independence maybe maybe came from that
but
you know i i don't i can't point to
something that happened in my childhood
that you know adversity if you said i
mean um
yeah yeah i was very fortunate
but i do think probably that
independence of going to boarding school
which i loved um and that independence
of
you know you're nine years old and you
go to heathrow and you know it's in the
days where you'd fly to the far east and
you you fly to germany you fly from
germany to the middle east you fight for
the middle east to the next spot and
then yeah
it was you know it's when planes didn't
go very far um
back in the day but um
but no so i i can't i can't point
something that from that perspective i
mean my father was always
he set businesses up that's what we
ended up moving around so he worked for
big corporate businesses
i suppose at the forefront of i suppose
globalization he worked for big uk
us corporates and he would set up their
businesses in in
singapore malaysia hong kong japan and
they would move on to the next
the next business so i suppose we were
always there was always an element of a
startup type
not startup but there was always an
element of sales entrepreneurism
um my sister runs her own business and
my brother runs his own business so
there's gonna be something in our
upbringing yeah yeah that meant that
we're
either not very good at taking orders or
something that's um something that's
affected us but
yeah i love that no i was just i was
just curious um so look i guess
very very quickly then because i want us
to focus on sort of john the business
owner
journey but obviously there's a lot to
unpack here right
been in the industry for a solid amount
of time
so like i guess if we to pack it all
together obviously your time and
a half which is a long amount of time
there's a couple of other companies that
i can see you work for before them but
like
how i guess we always want to talk about
people interested like how how would you
describe your sort of early days in
recruitment like what
what was john's early days of
recruitment
like what was that like for you how
would you describe it um
i mean so the early days i mean i didn't
really understand what recruitment was
when i first got into it
and you know very honestly i got a
job at stanford airport job centre
working for a technical recruitment
business
um sending people out to holland to to
work
um petrochemical welders that sort of
stuff
um i think pretty quickly i realized
that
you know i didn't i i enjoyed it
but it wasn't really that that
fulfilling in terms of sort of the
professionalism of what we were doing
you know i'd be advertising in the back
of the sun um you know so it didn't it
didn't necessarily
feel you know it was it was it was a
great business great sounding
um i then went and joined a uh
a finance and accounting recruitment
business um
a small business six of us in the office
i was basically just giving a senior
qual desk and it was like
speak to these people and this is what
you do and
i think i suppose back in back at that
point you know crms weren't there
you had you know cvs on your desk you
had not quite roller dexes but you know
all the cvs there so
i think in those days it was it was just
it was about building the relationships
it was it was
probably far more you had a small amount
of time you were posting cvs you were
you know
it was just it was just probably um
less less fast paced but but i'd
probably say longer
because you know i felt that probably
you were
you're working into the evenings more
because you had less time to contact
people you know there was no email there
was nothing you know so yeah
therefore it sort of things things
drifted drifted for a lot longer
i think um and it was great you know
recruitment's the same it did
you know your tools have changed but
actually what we're doing is still the
same i mean you know
we still meet candidates in the same way
we still do you just got teams to do it
now or zoom to do it now but um
yeah ultimately it hasn't changed that
much it's become more competitive it's
probably become
faster um but ultimately the
the the service we provide and and how
we do it and what makes people
good in the late 90s to make people good
at
you know the early 2020s i think the
skill sets are pretty much the same
still
um you know you have all the tools we
have today but if you don't do some of
the fundamentals and you can't build a
relationship and you can't
you can't do those things you're going
to really struggle in our industry
yeah so let's just go into
the last sort of ten years then so
obviously had a real solid amount of
time
working for other people so as you
mentioned
in your it sort of seemed like a sort of
uh you was destined to start your own
business potentially you may say
um but like obviously there's a lot of
people that say they're going to start
their own recruitment business
and then there's not as many people that
should do it so i guess i just always
like to start like what
what gave you the confidence in 2011 to
take that first step and
start your own recruitment business so i
would say i
was a yeah not not reluctant but it was
never
it was never necessarily on my career
plan yeah
if i went back 15 years and someone said
to me this is where you're going to be
in 10 years time i'd be like no no
that's that's that
not not because because of what we've
done it just just saw myself as this
i'm this corporate person and
and that was that was you know really
interesting i love my time at
robert half um and yeah i think
i i i don't know what it was but i think
i got to a point where
i just realized i was i was a passenger
in this ship
you know it wasn't it wasn't really
it wasn't really that fulfilling um it
wasn't really
yeah you weren't changing necessarily
people's lives internally externally
you know i don't quite maybe if i got
hit by a bus
the next person will be on take on my
role and you know 12 months later it's
john who
um and and so i think i
i think i just started to try and change
things and play around with things and
obviously that doesn't work in
in a corporate environment um so i think
you know it got to a point where it was
like right okay what do i want to do
um and i interviewed with lots of
smaller recruitment businesses thinking
all right well if if i go in as md or
ceo
got the opportunity to to change things
there's there's less risk for the family
um you know but you know if a company's
looking for a new ceo
the chances are this there's some
skeletons in the closet if you said i
mean
um so i sort of went through a few of
those processes
and and i suppose as as i got to the end
of it my father-in-law
um and and particularly my particularly
my father-in-law
and my brother-in-law um were both like
you you should do it yourself
and i'm like i don't know i don't know i
don't know um
and you know i suppose collectively
we're right okay if we put this amount
of money together
we can have a good good run at it
probably 12 months worth of decent
cash and we can hire a few people um
and let's give it a go you know i wasn't
walking out of
robert half with a bank of clients you
know i never had
clients of robert half it was it wasn't
how our role was if you said i mean it
was using the leadership position it
wasn't like
billing stuff yeah yeah and so and so
you know the
um i suppose inertia of going
wow i'm gonna have to start building
from the bottom i don't i don't have a
black book
i don't have client names you know it's
it's literally i'm starting from
from scratch and that was that sort of
held me back and they was like you know
what
actually i know i can do it
i know i was good at what i did um i
managed to find a couple of people
um one person who who joined me
she did all the admin and i'd worked
with her at
robert half for eight years so i trusted
her so she did basically everything
non-sales so it took
all of that stuff away from me she's
nice crms the the
the absolutely everything and all i had
to do
so it was sort of like in a really weird
way being in a corporate
but there was two of us if you said i
mean it's like i need this yeah she'd go
and sort it
and then i'd crack on so um yeah i went
back to my
qual finance days um that's that's what
we build
um you know i'd always looked after
finance technology and we launched a
little bit of an hr pilot at robert half
um so as always i wanted those three
brands um
and and i suppose then as we started to
go okay what else do our clients want
you started to pick up i suppose the the
executive positions
and yeah that needed a slightly
different delivery mechanism and
you know we go forward 10 years we have
multiple delivery mechanisms now for our
clients
um you know and it's very clear in terms
of when we speak to clients
what what service do they need and want
from us and
and what does that look like um but i
think you know certainly in the early
days
it wasn't like i'm going to go and set
my business up and i was prepping to do
that
it was you know fate whatever you want
to call it
and then you know i suppose those around
you going yeah no you can do it
you take it a belief to go all right
let's do it um my wife i also think you
did it in a smart way as well
12 you'll see not how many people will
go with like 12 months runway
not sure how many like you've got that
the obviously the higher on the ad the
support and admin side smart
because i think that's a lot of the
things that people underestimate the
amount of other stuff you have to do if
you're starting your own business on
your own
so i feel like you used it in a smart
way i feel like
yeah i mean i mean i i'd love to say all
of that was
and i think you know i think this is
this is yeah i talked to a lot of people
about
people who set up their own businesses
and all the rest of it and and i think
one of the traits
for some people is you can overthink it
yeah just just start
first step take that first step take the
first step
and you'll start to work stuff out you
know yeah it's not
it's not you know i've always with with
um uh chrissy who's this person i set up
with
um you know she was always like you need
strategies you need this you need this
and i'm like
well we do have a strategy but i'm not
going to spend
a day two days a week you know writing a
strategy document for the next 12 months
i need to place more people i need to
interview more people i need to
you know put out more contractors i need
to do this i need to do that
it's pretty clear what we need to do on
the sales side and then you know the
other stuff starts to look after itself
especially when you're a smaller
business
and then i suppose as you grow you then
need to
form your your your strategies your
visions and all the rest of it but the
vision hasn't changed from day one
the division has always been it was by
2041
so you know we moved on a bit and it's
now 25 in 25 and we're about eight
we're 10 years into or four years into
that um but it was always
25 locations by 2041 is where we wanted
to get to
that that's never changed it was always
about this global adventure
it was always about taking all the good
stuff from somewhere like robert half
taking the great stuff from previous
businesses i'd worked at
um and going right well how do we put
these together where
you only get one shot at career so let's
make sure we all enjoy it you know let's
make sure we
all share in the good stuff um and
yeah you know i've taken some risks at
the end of the day i might make
end up making a little bit more money
than everyone else but it's about going
on this adventure with people and going
you know i talked to a lot of people
about it like you know there will be a
day when
we're sitting somewhere in a far-flung
place in the earth and go
crap can you remember when we did this
podcast and um
we were 50 people and now we're x 100
people or with this or with that
and just having that ability to i
suppose reflect with people and enjoy
the adventure with those people
that's so important to me because this
isn't the john dyson show this is this
is about building something that
many many people could be super super
proud of their contributions
and knowing that we wouldn't be able to
do it without each other it's it's not a
it's not a solo journey
you know building a business is about
the collective and the better the
collective
the better you are yeah i love that so
what i'm keen to do john if it's okay
with you is just uh just to
um drill down in some like some
practical things
on on this business journey because i
know that's what people realize so
if we could just like if you could just
paint a picture for us on where the
business is today
and then we can go through i guess just
sort of a bit of the journey really as
um yes like where is the business you
said how many
people do you employ what are you
turning over how many locations etc
so we will probably do somewhere around
10 million something around that in in
sales
yeah we've got four to shade under 50
people
um yeah within the business probably
seven or eight of them are in
operational roles
so support functions finance hr
technology um we've got offices in
uh manchester london uh and chicago
um we started chicago beginning in may
and
we will have our edinburgh location
live probably at some point over august
beginning of september
um so yeah we'll be four four offices
in with a view that probably will have
another
location in the u.s um probably
first half of next year
we've we've stayed true to the to the i
suppose the verticals that we've spoken
about so finance
technology hr and the exec piece
um i think certainly from you know when
you start to go into the big
metropole markets those markets get
divided down a little bit more so you
know within london there's
specialist financial services and then
within financial services there's
there's further verticals that drop
below that um
but i suppose you when you start to look
at an office like a manchester business
um you know it's probably slightly more
geographical in terms of the focus
um sure so okay great so
yeah i guess so okay cool so then i
guess we'll just help i know it's not
just about headcount but it just helps
paint a bit of a picture for people so
just for context you were describing
them sort of really early days
so that's where you are today obviously
10 years is a long time so like
in the like first sort of three years
let's say like going into like the
fourth year where
like how many people did you have in the
business then maybe six years in and
then obviously the last bit just
to paint a picture for people on like
how long it's taken you know i think
it's important to
yeah showcase that so i think the
manchester business
um so we were very manchester centric
until we set the
the london business up three years ago
okay so
i think at at the peak probably
manchester was
or the business was so let's say after
seven years manchester was probably
about 30 heads we had about 30 heads in
the business
okay london then added in
the addition and then we've sort of
grown again in both of those locations
so so i suppose probably year three we
were
12 to 15 heads something like that um
we grew quite quickly in the first
couple of years and we were 10 heads
after about 18 months
so we grew quite quickly from that
perspective and we yeah i suppose the
focus
has always been this split between
permanent and and contract
and we try and make sure that 60 to 70
of our revenues are contract um
it's not always the case um but
certainly having that consistent
contract revenue in the
background and just supporting cash flow
with the interims
has been a massive part of us being able
to grow um
just because of the consistency and i
think you know again
that was a big lesson that came out
robert half in terms of the balance of
your business between perms
and contracts and the stability that can
give you
in terms of your business planning over
three to six months period yeah
okay thanks for sharing that so i guess
look i was saying this to you before so
let's just go into here because we're
talking about headcount growth and these
things
most um a lot of recruitment business
owners are in that sort of around that
15 head mark
or um 10 head mark and a lot of the
questions that i get from them is
just to i guess speak to people like you
who are further down the track on
how you have gone from that sort of 15
20
mark 2 30 40 50 because i feel that more
the more and more conversation i've had
that can be like a really difficult
transition
um to achieve that so i guess if i if
i'm someone that's listening that i do
have aspirations to
get to that it seems like you've just
mentioned the importance of if you don't
have a contract but that's something you
should be thinking about
but if i'm currently at that sort of 10
15 head mark and i know
i want to go to the that phase 40 plus i
guess what were some of the
biggest pains for you that you had to go
for what would be some of the sort of
key bits of advice that you'd give me
um i suppose the the first of all is
finding finding a p a a a very tight
group of people around you
that can share some of that burden yeah
once you go past
15 people you know you can't be
you can't necessarily be on top of
everyone every single day to give them
support and you also need to blend
i suppose the individuals coming into
your business you can't you can't
continue to hire people
at a mid to senior level you have to
start to train your own you have to
start bringing some of those sort of um
supposed people who are earlier in their
recruitment careers through so
so i suppose you know first and foremost
it's it's having
one maybe two other people that can
start to carry some of that
some of that sort of burden of bringing
people through i think that's that
that's a massive thing and that
that took a while to get right you know
it wasn't something we got right
straight away um and i think it's also
very important to make sure that you do
have one eye
on that blend within your business
otherwise you do end up with
you you go forward and then suddenly you
realize you've got four people who are
in exactly the same level
within the same part of your business
and two of them will go i'm off
and because you know there's no they
can't all progress to being
the manager of that team they can't all
so it's about
you know it's trying to make sure that
you're managing those careers and making
sure those individuals
understand exactly what their careers
are and
and and having that that mix of people
within the teams because i think
again yeah we've made those mistakes
where suddenly we've arrived at a point
and everything feels brilliant and
suddenly you have
you know a firm of 20 people
four people resign you've lost 20
percent you know
you know it's big and and you know
we all know in recruitment it feels like
resignations never come in their ones
it's like one goes and then someone goes
oh yeah
yeah that's true it starts to snowball
so so i suppose that that
that balance of of of making sure that
your teams are blended
um it's going to be important um so that
that'd be certain
um and i suppose for me
yeah probably making sure that um
you know from a personal perspective you
understand that your business will have
to change as you grow
you know when you're you know whatever
you know when you're a team of 10 people
your business is just
of a size and scale that is so different
to 20 people
and i know that sounds but it's but
suddenly you've got
so many other things that take your
attention away you've got so many other
things that start to happen
within your business um and i think
therefore having those people around and
going okay well
what are the things that are absolute
true
you know pillars you know i talk about
you know
people passion principle performance so
you get the right people with the right
traits
that they're passionate about
recruitment
um they're passionate about you know
going out and
and not not selling but but they enjoy
recruitment you've got to enjoy what you
do so you're passionate about that
principle that gets kicked around a lot
you know how many big corporates have
principles you know their sort of thing
but
suppose principle for me is how would
you like your brother or your mother or
your sister or your
your best mate to be treated as they go
through a recruitment process
and and just treat your candidates like
that that that's how i want you to treat
your candidates
like not like they're your best mate and
you have to pick the phone up all the
time but
keeping them updated and all the rest of
it and if you do those three things you
will get performance you will get
you know if you're passionate about it
people feel that passion and they'll
come back to you
you know principles so so i suppose it's
keeping what's really cool
and then going some of the other stuff
it works when you're 10 people
but when you're 15 20 it doesn't
um you know it may be that the guy that
runs i don't know
team a he might want to take his team
out
as a team of six and it's like where's
my invite you know and it's like that's
not your team anymore john you need
you need to let go you need to allow
them to build
the culture within their team and and i
suppose it's it's having
having a uh a vision of what's
absolutely key to you and your business
and then what's the stuff that
yeah it was really good when we were 10
people or 15 people but
right okay well now it's your turn to
carry that bat on and and
and not always be the person that
that comes in to solve things because
yeah otherwise you you never
you never break those those um
cut the apron strings whatever you want
to call it um and that really does
hamper growth that if you're always the
person that has to be there to
to yeah yeah pick those things up how
what what's been your journey with that
because i was having a really
interesting
and i feel like that can be like a
really common barrier because
like i think some people as you said
like where you started like you just
you just want to sell you want to do the
deals and you want to be involved in
these types of things and
that's most of the stories most people
were recruiters and that before they
obviously started their own recruitment
business right so they've always been
involved with that and
there's a really interesting chat with a
business owner the other day who
is sort of a year 18 months away from
hopefully
um getting to a point um of an event in
his business and he wants to give there
an opportunity
to his employees or other people to buy
into the business take it to the next
level and
he's really had to go on this journey of
like getting out of his own way because
he used to be the person that could name
all the contractors on their book and
he was one of their biggest performers
and stuff like that but over the last
year or so to make this business more
valuable
and make sure like you said you're not
the person that's always solving the
problems or has relied on
obviously then all of a sudden john's
got to work out what his purpose is and
what
like within this business that you
started right i guess i'm just curious
as to like what
what's your journey been like with that
has it been quite easy to get out of
your own way is that
yeah um no
it's not yes yes and no i suppose you
know what what
limited our growth in terms of the next
location
there was a big trust thing there was a
big massive trust thing for me
um and you know neil who
who joined joined the business and you
know invested in the business
um you know that trust
because we worked together for for a
number of years at half
there was just this trust and it's like
yeah i'm i'm
there are the keys you know let me know
what you want but
crack on you know i'll give you some
trust for you so trust in another person
to
trust another person to to do it um yeah
i think manchester for a long time was
you know
i suppose it was it was you know my baby
if you said i mean um yeah yeah
and i think again you know everyone
who's been through our doors
and may have left may still be here yeah
they all played a massive
part in getting us to where we got to
yeah absolutely and and i think
you know i'd like to think that you know
the majority of people that have left
our business
think think well about business you know
wish us well and all the rest of it you
know we haven't had many
uh acrimonious departures or anything
like that um
but i think it is then trying to find as
you grow right well
sometimes there is a six month
transition or a transition period where
it's like
you just have to as you said get out of
your own way
and you might not really know what
you're doing as in
i found myself doing a load of
just pure recruitment you know i was
like a consultant at home
um i had the rest of the business but i
was just running my own assignments
and you know i was i was i was there on
the end of the phone for for
for you know for people that required me
but it was like
they need the space they don't need me
in manchester they
they're they're they're a good group and
i suppose i ended up
just putting fees on the board probably
for about three to six months just
just doing that and and i suppose that
allowed me to feel like at least i've
got a sense of purpose
there was parts of times where i was
like john you've gone back 10 years
and it's like well you're putting your
fees into your own business john so get
over yourself and crack on
uh yeah so you know it's and and
suddenly you enjoy it again and then you
realize why you
did the job in the first place for
something so it's like it's trying to
make sure that you keep remembering some
of the things and then
you do you're able to sit down with the
guys in the office when they do ask for
help and it's like well
this is what i did the other day and
this is how this worked and they're like
oh yeah yeah
the old dinosaur in the corner can still
still do some stuff
um you know so it's it's it's sort of i
i think it's it's
i suppose yeah it gets said a lot
doesn't it but it's like
you're never too big to do the little
things in the business so you know
if you're struggling to know what to do
pick up the phone and start speaking to
clients
get some jobs on for the teams go do
something that's
you know is going to help the business
might feel
like you left that behind well it'd be
good to reconnect with
certain people whatever it might be and
i think you know certainly one of the
things that you know we've always spoken
about
myself neil now max is we have to be
able to point to revenue
we have to be able to point to clients
that we're bringing in every month we
might not be fulfilling
but we need to be able to hand and rain
make or whatever you want to go
because that's really important for the
team you know and i think sometimes in
the bigger
bigger bigger corporate businesses you
know you said at the beginning
leadership and it's like well there's
got to be a
little bit of leadership around sort of
the client side as well and i think that
sometimes can get can get lost
um so i think in getting out my own way
it was probably all right well just
pull up a chair and let's let's go yeah
but i guess the
the key thing there is that yeah so
you're saying you can reconnect with
that and actually that's been a quite
positive thing for you but you've got to
make sure
if you are going to scale you are going
to grow that you can't be relied on
you can't be it can't be john we could
let's call john and he'll sort this for
us like you've got to get way beyond
that
but yeah okay so what um a couple of
things
one really interested to hear like in
your opinion like what's been
the most critical hire out of interest
as you've grown this business like
what's been the glue that's made this
business you think has it been
that sort of team that might be growing
in the in the back office or i don't
know i have interest for you what's been
one of the most critical hires that you
think has one of the biggest impacts
i think the the the biggest
the biggest critical hires for me have
been i suppose my immediate team
okay the ones that i can um
the ones that we can sit down as a group
of managing partners and go right
how are we gonna how are we gonna tackle
that and yeah i don't have all the
answers but to be able to
you know i suppose if i look at the last
three years having neil on the end of
the phone and going
mate i've had a [ __ ] day um and just
being able to be
i've had a [ __ ] to share that with
people it's amazing how empowering
that actually is um and you know i think
solving these problems you know you'll
see it one way someone else will see it
a different way someone else will see it
another way and
ending up with this sort of um so
probably better solutions
so i think certainly for me you know the
the the piece that
fundamentally helped us grow was the
trust levels i had in neil
the trust that i've built with max those
two now have enabled us to go
right okay you can do that you can do
that and we're all very confident
in each other there's not a there's not
a you know i need
number one you know i'm pecking order
here it's
you know collectively we're a team and
we we go from there um
i think latterly um last six months or
so
it's probably been getting a really
strong finance person involved
we had someone who was involved with us
for probably two years
two two and a half years almost like his
non-exec cfo
um and that was almost like an overlord
of the finances
and that was really useful because you
know they they helped
um scale previous recruitment businesses
so
they weren't a salesperson but they were
a finance person they'd seen lots of
different comp plans lots of different
things lots of different that
and i suppose having that just totally
external
probably non-robert half background
because myself
and many others in our business have
come through robert half
has been very very beneficial and
certainly sort of going through
the last 12 months 18 months that's been
massive
you know having someone who i could rely
on yeah sure
that was that was gonna be my next
question like have you had any
experience in i don't know finding them
like because it seems like what's really
obviously propelled the business but
also you personally is yeah having
these uh obviously yeah other can call
them like co-founders later down the
line whatever you want to call them or
other
sort of directors in the business that
you can really trust that you back
and like you said can share some of this
this burden with right
yeah i was gonna ask you yeah have you
had in your journey so far how do you
engage in a
sort of maybe having a mentor or an nd
so it seems like you did do that
but it was more obvious it's actually
someone from a cfo background
yeah so she was jewish from a finance
background um he was less of a mentor um
i have worked with uh like a business
coach
okay uh who actually i got introduced to
at robert half
so so he's someone i've worked with for
12 years very very on and off
but but yeah it's probably someone in
the early days that helped me
define stuff um i've always been
quite into i suppose business
business books but like you know
self-development business yeah
what sort of legacy by james kerr
yeah that's great brilliant we got james
kerr to come and speak to us
so we do really our annual annual big
party and we had
we had him come and speak and that was
immense you know
amazing this is where sometimes as an
owner you sit there and you go
right he normally does this to 300
400 people and he's sitting in a room of
30 of you and you're like
yeah well you know you can indulge
yourself once in a while but
big shout out to james kerr that was a
brilliant day we've had
um paul mcgee who wrote the sumo guy
um so that was a that's a brilliant book
it's a bit more
personal self-help sort of shut up and
move on and it's about how do you
overcome
obstacles um we've had a couple of other
people come and speak at the events
and i think those sort of people just
help you define stuff i've got to say
james kerr in legacy
there's lots of things that he speaks
about in that book
that have become very ingrained in us as
a business like there is a lot of things
from that
particular book that i i would say if
you are looking to
well like the one or two things yeah
what are they
well yeah what what would you say like
one of the two things that i'm
interested in one of the things
one of the big things is is i mean
there's there's the adage of like the no
[ __ ] but that
that is one of the obvious ones but i
suppose one of the things is
you will have people on your on the
adventure
they're not going to be with you forever
and you need to celebrate the fact that
someone was being with you for three
years and they've done a brilliant job
and if they decide to leave
they've left your business hopefully in
a better position so thank them for it
don't be bitter about it and you know
it's it's that sort of time in the sun
sort of thing and
you know we're all doing this so
hopefully next year
the people that join us it's it's easier
and better for them
to come into our business just because
we had it hard just because i started
with nothing
doesn't mean i want someone else to
start with nothing and i suppose it's
that
that sort of uh vision of every day
we're trying to make it better for the
new people joining our business
those that haven't even joined us yet
yeah we want to try and make it as good
as possible
so when they do come in they can be the
best version of themselves
again if you sell me and then it's there
yeah their job is to make it better for
the next group
so you're always trying to strive to to
make it better for the new people coming
into the business
yeah and i think that's definitely
hasn't always been a mindset and
recruitment has it and obviously
as a business owner you want to protect
your business if you have someone leaves
that
you're gonna do the exact same vertical
and they've been a bit shady of course
you're gonna act but i think you i think
that's just the better mindset to have
isn't it you'd rather
leave on good terms and you never know
what might happen in a year two years
time that person
might go you know what john i've tried
to build this recruitment business it's
[ __ ] way harder than i thought it was
i really enjoyed my time at fjr i'd love
to be able to come back and
like you're not even gonna have that
opportunity if you made it
made them just feel horrible and like it
wasn't a nice departure you know i mean
so
i'll just yeah i love that um how um
so i love the fact that you said that
you've been working with a business
coach i guess anything on that i've
spoke to recently another recruitment
business owner that's recently engaged
with a business coach and said that
it's been really transformative anything
else to share on that
i haven't heard many business owners on
here say that they've worked actively
business coaching anything else that
you feel like has had to help i know you
said it helps you define things and
stuff like that but anything worth
sharing that
it's really impacts you on what helped
you in building this business do you
think it's worth sharing i think
i think certainly in the early days
you had a million a million different
thoughts going through your mind about
the different
challenges and i suppose where it was
really useful working with simon
was you you you'd walk in cluttered
and you'd walk out with a
very clear idea of what you were going
to do but not a plan
but most of it was around communication
most of it was around all right so
this is what you got to you know what
you got to do you know most people in
recruitment know what they've got to do
you know you know what the challenge is
right so
so how are you going to communicate with
that team how are you going to do this
and and he was super super helpful in
helping me
frame conversations frame right okay so
how do i how do i say this and he would
make me role-play
you know i felt like a rookie again you
know while playing it down the phone to
him and
you know and but you know what when i
look back and i i remember sort of doing
it for the first time the engagement
that we got and then the
i suppose the the camaraderie and and i
suppose the togetherness we got from
really practicing right what what do i
want people to hear
what do i want to say but what do i want
them to hear is the most important bit
um that was really useful working with
the coach so it was less around
probably me and how do i make my
business better but
right okay so how are you going to help
me specifically communicate these
messages he's not going to do it i've
got to do it
but using that person is a really good
sounding board and
and human and how the human mind works
and
he you know the dog brain and all this
sort of stuff
you know he he's worked with in the
military
and he's worked with a very high level
within sport
and yeah he's all around that sort of
sporting mentality
not sporting mentality the how that how
how you engage the brain how you engage
not your brain
other people's brains to get people
together so you know certainly from that
perspective
in that probably years two
to two to eight that was really powerful
when the business was growing and you
just
it was it was it wasn't therapy in any
way it was
right okay these are my challenges help
me solve some of these and let me walk
out with a defined plan that i now need
to go and execute
yeah nice so it's a couple of things on
the ask you before we finish definitely
ask you
just sort of what the journey's been
like in the last 12 18 months of the
business and
where you're heading but on this topic
like what's been
always talk about mindset and everything
on there on this podcast like what's
been
um your journey with your own mental
health during this period
i guess don't have to talk about the
last 12 18 months but overall and
building this business how what's that
been like for you
it seems like you quite invested in
getting help or open-minded like so
yeah i'm very fortunate
you know i've got three young kids i've
got um
a a wife that takes no [ __ ] um
and i've got you know a brilliant
extended family in the local local area
so
yeah from that perspective i'm pretty
lucky clearly in the last 10 years
there's been times when you're like
crap this yeah if this all goes wrong
you're screwed you know you've got you
know you've got this you've got that
you've got this you've got that
and there have been times you know there
have been times when i've sat on
i've sat in my car and i've gone oh my
god
and you know i've i've had a moment you
know um
but you know during those times i've
been able to pick up the phone um
and i've i've been lucky that i've got
that that sort of group around me
i mean but yeah it is it is super lonely
um it can be because sometimes you're
the only one that really really knows
the skeletons in the cupboard what's
going on yeah
but what i would say is going back to
finding those people you can trust
when you find those people you can trust
and you can talk about those skeletons
they sort of you work out how to get rid
of them
whereas when is it just you and that
skeleton and you know you're facing off
it's a lot tougher and that's why i
encourage people and that's why you know
i think certainly from my perspective
you know bringing neil into the business
um
was awesome um it really was and and you
know
latterly having max in the business for
the last couple of years has been
awesome
um you know just did that that pool and
then
i said right now nieves who's joined as
the cfo
um you've got four people that we've all
got different ideas and we can we can
share them so
you know and i think we're good at
trying to look after each other's
mindsets
and you can tell when each other are
down but you know it's it's nice now
yeah we can jump on a call and every
monday we have our kickoff call
and you know there's always a good bit
of banter and yeah you've got that
that that team piece um yeah as for the
last 18 months
um i mean i put something on linkedin
you know i'm
i'm staggered um how well
most people have have sort of
the resilience of people um you know
everyone's had their moments in the last
18 months you know
i think anyone who said it's been a walk
in the park is
is probably being a little bit
disingenuous but um
how how different people have bounced
back at different times how
other people have sort of picked each
other up how how good everyone was when
it was like
you know you go back to last march we
were on a ski slope on
on the big adventure you know we had the
top performers away we were in valterran
we were at the top of the mountain we
were king of the world oh wow it was
it was phenomenal and we got back on
saturday night and it was like you need
to be out of the hotel by
midday tomorrow otherwise you're being
impounded and it was like oh [ __ ]
neither airport was crazy and all the
rest of it but
not necessarily that group because that
that group were just amazingly hung over
and weren't able to do anything
in the weeks after that how quickly
people came together and how quickly
you saw people accept things deal with
things
um you know you had the the first bit if
you have asthma
you have to work from home if you've got
this and suddenly someone put their hand
up and god
i've got ass murdered and you're like
well could you leave the office please
you know it was you know some of these
things you forget how
draconian suddenly it became but yeah
i'm
massively proud of how the team you know
developed we i don't think we did
anything massively different to a lot of
other people
the zoom calls this and all the rest of
it but you know like
many people just just really proud about
how how they they
looked after each other um we we
we tried very hard um but it's um you
know certainly from from my perspective
you know it still feels it still feels
like you know
there's the more chapters in the
covid pandemic to run doesn't feel like
it's quite going to be this
nice serene exit from the pandemic that
we're all hoping yeah
i mean i can continue what's been like
the last quarter how's it been for the
last quarter for you guys because i
continue to hear
how busy everyone is and people i'm sure
you've seen it on linkedin
record-breaking months quarters all
these things like
how how is it how has it been now i
guess yeah come and start coming out the
other side and
what are you excited about yeah it's you
know
clearly there are businesses that are
hiring now and
you know every thing everyone sees it
you know the all the data is there's
there's a lot going on in the market and
it's super exciting
and i think probably the market over the
next 12 months
is probably as good as the market as
we're going to have for
for a long long time you know it's going
to temper off um
you know as i suppose we get back to
sort of a bit more business as usual
i think the really exciting thing is we
we've over the past 18 months
we've we've solidified what we've got in
london um
you know we've managed to to keep that
going during the during the pandemic
you know we're then on the front foot
we've got chicago now going
we've got clients in chicago we've got
edinburgh suddenly you're like
when you start to break down our 25 by
25 or 25
it's like we're on track you know
this is yeah we are going to do this
guys you know and
and i think the fact that we've broken
the the first
you know i don't say international
places we've done lots of international
placements
from the uk but like we've we've done
that we're on the
you know that that that cherry has been
popped you know we are we are active
we've got our own business in the in the
us
and suddenly you're like oh man this is
so exciting i mean when
when james called me on wednesday
evening to tell me he'd done his deal
i was like hopping around the streets
like a man
it was just brilliant and and you know i
think
it's those little milestones that you
sort of
i'll remember that forever now yeah
that's that's that's that's one of the
baked in moments of
fjr history i mean and you know there's
not many of them and as i get older i
probably forget some of the earlier ones
but
you know it's it's really really
important to to celebrate those those
milestones because
you know there are the things that you
know everything starts with the first
step the first deal the first this
but suddenly you can get that momentum
and i think you know certainly the
moment it feels like one the front foot
with uh
a ton of really good stuff about to
happen yeah i love that
so i've got final question for you is um
if you could change the industry what
what would you improve
if i could change the industry what
would i improve um
i would love everyone to have a little
bit more respect
for what we do i think we've done a
really good job over the last
20 years in some of our price pricing
for a race to the bottom and and i think
therefore we get treated
as an industry um
how we price ourselves if that makes
sense so i think sometimes
we've ended up giving ourselves a bad
reputation by not valuing the service
and i think certainly one of the things
that i've
noticed very quickly in north america
is how much more respect they have for
staffing people
and i would love i'd love to be able to
correct that because
people give their heart and souls to
their clients and candidates but i think
we've
we've whether it's through pricing
whether it's through behaviors
but certainly i think i'd love to have
that level of respect where
you know you don't sit at dinner and go
what do you do a recruitment
yeah yeah a great uh whereas you know
it's it's
it you know speaking to clients in the
us they're like yeah yeah
you provide a service and they're
prepared to pay for it but they also
want that pound of flesh
for it i mean so it goes both ways but
i i i love the fact that there's a
better level of respect
um and i think that's one thing i'd love
to have changed love that
john it's been an absolute pleasure
thanks for being so open and honest it's
uh
excited to we definitely have to get you
uh back on when
yeah on the other side of this 25 25 25
or absolutely another yeah be amazing
well um
john ben absolute pleasure and thanks
for coming on perfect